whitney's in minneapolis hi Whitney
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
taking my call
sure what's up so I recently got
divorced I am 33 and I'm a single mom
with two kids and I have a ton of
student loan debt I have a really good
job but my student loans are killing me
not to mention just being a single
parent it's pretty tough so I'm just
going to see if I I do own some land and
I'm wondering I have one student loan
that sir exhaust that's about twenty
five thousand dollars and then it's
really just with Wells Fargo that's been
an issue for me
so I contemplated taking a mortgage out
against my land the payoff just those
loans to one lower my interest rate and
then to also get rid of that charged off
account and then the other $25,000
student loan debt at Wells Fargo what
else have you got
so twenty five thousand is charged off
at Wells Fargo I have about another 20
thousand OS Wells Fargo and then I have
about another hundred thousand dollars
in student loans as you have a hundred
and forty five thousand dollars in
student loan debt
yep Wow how much do you owe on your car
um well I am loosing my cars no crap
how much is your alignment for fifteen
cheese what is your income 72,000 mm-hmm
how much is your house payment I rent
right now that's the other thing do you
play for rent close to 1600
all right and how many kids have you got
I have two what ages t14 hmm hands are
full and how much child support are you
getting in addition to seventy two
thousand four hundred dollars four
hundred dollars on
yes he doesn't work much does he he's a
business owner your attorney sucks then
or he doesn't he doesn't make any profit
okay what's the land worth and what's
the story on the land yeah so it's
farmland it's been in my family we have
I share it with my brother we share 88
earth so I have about 40 which would be
flat my checks over a hundred thousand
dollars well your brother by your part
out I asked him he's not in a position
to right now so then I won't because
it's just it was my dad's he's no longer
here mm-hmm
he's no longer here but you have two
children to raise you have a hundred and
forty-five thousand dollars in student
loan debt and you have a $100,000 piece
of dirt sitting over there yes you don't
have a choice it's good dirt I know I
agree I know someone that's not family
I'm sorry no choice your brother says
taking a mortgage out well you get
what's the difference you got debt or
you got dad you still got a hundred
forty five thousand dollars with a debt
and a piece of dirt over there and
you're trying to raise two babies I'm
sorry I hate that you're in this
situation I know this is heartbreaking
but I gotta tell you this is a piece of
dirt your your children's future and
your future is at stake your dad did not
give you that piece of dirt for it
doesn't be anything except a blessing I
agree I agree and I want to do that it's
just not it's frowned upon to do that
crap who frowns upon it if somebody
wants to frown upon it they can write
you the check right that's true you just
don't you don't have a lot of options
you're in a pinch I am in but the thing
is I have like a like two months to
figure this out cuz I have to leave the
town home they're selling it so that I
don't have a lot of time to make a
decision
you're gonna be renting you're broke
yeah you're not gonna be buying anything
so you so the townhome you're living in
has given you notice that you have to
leave yeah okay so you just gotta find
you another rental property
you gotta move got a fun place for you
and the kids to move rent and you got to
get this land so get this student loan
what if you had no payments I could I
agreed yeah and you can start saving for
your kids college and you can start
saving for your retirement and your
future would start to brighten up again
after this horrible thing you've been
through and this jerk of an ex who
doesn't even take care of his own kids
yeah $400
give me a break I know and so I mean you
you you are the secret sauce to these
problems you and bless your heart you're
just throwing out there in the cold I
mean I'm not picking on you I'm on your
side I want you to win and I know you've
been had the crud knocked out of you and
you've been scared and you've been mad
and you've been all those things right
mm-hmm
yeah and this piece of dirt clears up a
lot of your problems I agree and getting
rid of this get rid this lease car yes I
agree you didn't have any payments
you had an inexpensive rent you're
living on a budget you and these kids
start to have a really bright future
because you do have a decent income what
do you do for a living I'm a mental
health therapist I'm a trauma therapist
okay okay cool so you're getting a
little of your own medicine right now
aren't you you tell people every day
things they don't want to hear but are
the truth and are good for them mm-hmm
that's what I'm doing to you right I can
take it I know you can take it honey I'm
not trying to make you do it I'm just
saying you you tell people the truth
every day again in uncomfortable awkward
situations and that's what I'm doing I I
know this land means a lot to you I know
there's going to be some people roll
their eyes and so forth but the problem
is they're not sending you any money
take care of your babies right and so
you have to do what's good for you and
these two babies that is that's the only
people you need to impress right
Medicare if they want to give you
$100,000 and keep the land in the family
that's wonderful
I'd that be there would be a wonderful
thing but if they can't do that or we
won't do that then there we go and you
know that they lose their right to gripe
about someone's else's life when they
refuse to help them you're in a
situation I'm so sorry
that's what I would do if I woke up in
your shoes and I know it's painful it's
going to be less painful than trying to
wade out of this and you can't borrow
your way out of debt